If the temperature outside changes
by half a degree,
you won't even feel it.
Such a small change is almost
imperceptible to human senses.
But half a degree of global
temperature change could be
little short of the end of the world
we recognise.
Or at least the world humanity has
inhabited for the last few millennia.
In 2015, governments agreed a deal
in Paris to stop global warming
rising past 2 degrees and to
try to keep it below 1.5 degrees.
So what's in half a degree?
At 1.5 degrees,
there would still be some
precious rainforests, polar bears
and coral reefs on planet Earth,
albeit seriously diminished.
Sea levels would rise,
but relatively slowly,
so major cities like London, Jakarta
and Mumbai have a better chance of
continuing life as normal.
Drought and flooding would be at
a level where food production
can keep up with population growth.
Millions of extra climate
refugees could stay at home
and others could avoid starvation.
Getting to this world isn't
impossible, it means cutting
greenhouse gas emissions
by half within a decade
And then being carbon neutral
by mid-century.
So we'd be closing
coal power stations instead of
building new ones
and every car would be electric.
We'd be restoring forests
instead of cutting them down,
and even aircraft
would be carbon neutral.
It's not impossible,
but it is unlikely.
The fossil fuels lobby is powerful.
Some heads of state even deny
the reality of climate change.
Transforming the global energy system
will take time,
and trillions
of dollars of investment.
But it's also an opportunity.
So if we're too slow and
instead of 1.5, we get the extra
half degree - what then?
According to the latest IPCC report,
in a world two degrees warmer,
you'd go diving in the tropical seas
but the flourishing
coral reefs are gone.
Instead, you would likely see a
graveyard of rubble and algae.
Back on land, heatwaves
are becoming increasingly deadly,
with approximately 65 million
extra people exposed to
exceptional heatwaves each year.
Imagine yourself at the North Pole,
but all you see is open water.
The polar bears are gone
along with the sea ice that
used to be their home.
You take a boat to the edge of
Greenland, but that frozen wasteland
is thawing.
Huge meltwater rivers thunder into
the ocean, where they add to the
rising sea levels that are beginning
to flood the world's coastlines.
Take a trip to Miami,
Mumbai or Melbourne
and you'll probably need a boat.
Faced with the rising seas,
10 million people could be forced
to pack up and move.
Global harvests would also suffer,
and in developing
countries especially
the number of people experiencing
water scarcity doubles.
This would be a world of increasing
poverty and human misery.
All for what? For half a degree.
And for a few more years
of coal smoke stacks
and oil industry profits.
The choice is ours, but not for long.
Every bit of warming, every year,
every choice matters.
But like a desert mirage,
the 1.5 degree world is receding
into the distance
with every year we delay.
If carbon emissions keep growing for
decades to come,
then even two degrees looks hopeful.
That's a world - a darker world -
of flood, fire and conflict
that we can barely even imagine.
We can still choose
that half a degree window
between unsettling dream
and full-blown nightmare.
But it's closing fast.
Thanks for watching. Don't forget to subscribe
and click the bell to receive notifications for new videos.
See you again soon.